[Music]
and how about Chrissy Teigen and John
Legend love them together i watch their
wedding video like once a week
yesterday was Chrissy's 32nd birthday
and they celebrated in high-flying retro
style Chrissy cleared for takeoff with
Kim Kayne friends this party was
certainly hubby John Legend serenaded
the birthday girl both took Chrissy's
vintage 60s Pan Am theme to new heights
we see that Jackie O inspired look oh my
gosh G yes the black fascinator the pink
Power Suit the tiny belt since just
above her baby bump yep Chrissy was all
in her food leaving little Luna at home
they and some schlub friends gathered at
this makeshift LAX terminal constructed
to the team with a ticket counter
stewardesses and a replica double-decker
plane complete with pilots and a safety
briefing take the metal end and its
object into the box hole but at at about
three months pregnant we never expected
to see Chrissy do this not to worry it's
fake but Kanye winning bingo that's real
not exactly dressing the part Kanye let
his Instagram happy wife Kim shine in a
pink Chanel suit sunglasses and a 60s
beehive Chrissy appreciated the effort
anyone can dine inside the Pan Am plane
replica for upwards of four hundred and
thirty dollars a plate cause she's
drinking in first class already